pour
pour madison tourner à droite talent et
free ont tous fait le droit pour rien
son look un drapeau
salut moi c'est arrivé sally ride
c'est parti pour dix huit heures de
route
je te préviens la réussite passera
jamais rien entre nous
ça tombe bien j'ai trouvé quelqu'un pour
m'emmener salut salut qu'à trois ferrari
en chantier c'est typiquement le genre
de mec à qui j'avais dissimule hills
du haut des moments nous dit au sénat
une bonne note
mais
elle
bates motel à éviter absolument le
patron pour habitude de se déguiser en
sa mère morte et de tuer les clients
sous la douche étoilé au formulaire mois
walibi est moche next de quoi allécher
palais ou femme est jack m juliette
non c'est une capulet tintin hergé mais
tous les chiffres et cela a du coup ça
dégage à lélex bon thé chaud pour un jeu
de paume moi allez on y va
je sais qu'ils sont là puisque je vous
dis que vous ne trouverez jamais ici bas
si je sais pas ce que j'ai l'application
localiser mes amis donc du coup
attendait bougez pas je trouvais
attendez attendez c'est pas moi c'est
juste là bas vous êtes de succès vous
pourquoi pour moi ces praticiens
pratique ces petites applications
écoutez je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée merci à vous
je suis éperdument amoureux jours pour
être un
ce n'est pas comme ça j'arrive pas à
prendre la photo du matin au caire où
beaucoup se mettre un petit fils